[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
on va continuer à parler cette semaine
des conséquences de l'épidémie de covin
mais pas seulement
et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission brigitte boucher bonjour
bonjour tam est notre invité cette
semaine est à la tête du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée c'est
le député de paris
gilles legendre bonjour j de légende ou
rothen traduit bonjour aux yeux bouchés
aujourd'hui la jambe et c'est brigitte
qui va commencer par brosser votre
portrait j légende vous êtes né le 13
mai 1958 à neuilly-sur-seine dans les
hauts-de-seine vous êtes président du
groupe la république en marche député de
paris mme acronis de la première heure
vous défendez coûte que coûte la
politique du gouvernement face aux
critiques vous ne concéder qu'une erreur
celle d'avoir probablement été trop
intelligente sur les mesures liées au
pouvoir d'achat c'était à l'époque après
le bac
ce sera sciences po il cfj votre coeur
balance entre deux spécialités parmi les
plus décriées par les français la
politique et le journalisme vous avez
occupé plusieurs postes de direction à
l' usine nouvelle au nouvel économiste à
l'expansion l'événement du jeudi où
challenge avant d'arriver à l'assemblée
mais aujourd'hui vous êtes rattrapé par
vos premières amours puisque l'économie
française connaît une crise sans
précédent
une récession de 11% un déficit de 11,4
pour cent estimé à fin 2020 alors quel
oeil acéré aurait porté le journaliste
économique indépendant forcément sur
cette crise économique sans précédent
écoutez j'ai attendu d'avoir 62 ans pour
vivre probablement lé élevé d'événements
économiques le plus bouleversant qui est
connue la planète depuis la guerre est
donc en tant qu'observateur que je ne
suis plus probablement en or et j'étais
passionné et il n'y a qu'à lire les
journaux ou en regarder la télévision
entendre les radios pour voir à quel
point cette crise suscite des réflexions
des interrogations des interpellations
qui aurait été probablement été les
miennes si j'étais encore journaliste
que je ne suis plus quand même depuis
près de vingt ans donc le lot a coulé et
dit le maintien aujourd'hui mais
maintenant mais massa auteur mais
maintenant nous sommes acteurs
et nous avons à relever tous ensemble un
défi phénoménal c'est à dire être
capable de répondre à cette crise avec
probablement des solutions totalement
inédites parce que cette crise là est
inédite et ce que je voudrais être
saluée aujourd'hui c'est précisément
l'option que très tôt avant même que la
pandémie prennent tous sont sinistres
élan le gouvernement et notamment bruno
le maire ont tout de suite compris que
nous étions dans un schéma totalement
inédit et qu'il fallait faire éclater
les cadres habituels les règles
habituelles y compris vous l'avez dit
les règles de rigueur budgétaire qui ne
s'appliquait plus dans ce contexte là
elles reviendront et nous devrons être
rigoureux dans la manière dont nous
dépensons l'argent mais d'être capable
d'aller tout de suite chercher des
solutions inédites ce qui a été fait
avec le chômage partiel avec le fonds de
soutien avec le les prêts garantis par
l'état etc etc
gilles légende on va continuer à parler
et des conséquences du coc vite dans
cette émission avec d'abord une
commission d' enquête sur l'épidémie de
kovy de 19 elle va débuter ses travaux
mi juin sous la houlette du rapporteur
les république eric ciotti qui veulent
la vérité sur la gestion des masques et
de 10 1 10e groupe parlementaire s'est
créé à l'assemblée nationale deux
groupes ont vu le jour en deux semaines
avec des députés issus de la majorité
mais pas seulement la crise couve dans
cette majorité
enfin assouplir le régime des
procurations et améliorer la
participation lors du deuxième tour des
municipales fixées le 28 juin c'est
l'objectif d'une proposition de loi
adoptée cette semaine au sénat
la balle est désormais dans le camp de
la santé et on commence par le premier
thème de cette émission l'assemblée qui
va enquêter sur l'épidémie de
coronavirus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mission d'information sur le co vide
19 lancers en mars dote des pouvoirs
d'enquêté pour six mois
vraies prérogatives d'une commission
denquête c'était une demande des
républicains évoqué pour septembre elle
débutera finalement ses travaux dès la
mi juin presque en même temps que celle
du sénat les précisions de stéphanie des
pierres c'est 30 députés vont enquêter
sur la gestion de l'épidémie de
coronavirus qu'ils peuvent convoquer qui
ils veulent et les auditions se font
sous serment
l'opposition attend les premiers
témoignages avec impatience le député
les républicains eric ciotti a obtenu le
poste clef de rapporteur général
l'objectif c'est la vérité c'est faire
la vérité sur ce qui s'est passé sur ce
qui a fonctionné mais aussi sur ce qui a
dysfonctionné sur nos failles sur
certaines faillite le champ
d'investigation est très large masquer
ce test gestion des ehpad confinement
déconfinement le patron des républicains
est l'un des quatre vice-présidents de
la commission denquête il promet que la
droite n'en fera pas un procès politique
l'objectif voilà c'est d'éviter c'est
d'éviter finalement qu'on fasse un
benalla bis l'objectif ce n'est pas d'en
faire un tribunal populaire de viser la
responsabilité judiciaire de tel ou tel
ministre
non notre objectif c'est la
responsabilité politique des
défaillances dysfonctionnements les
failles qui a eu dans le système à l'été
2010 8 la commission benalla avait
implosé après des divergences sur les
personnes à auditionner la majorité se
prépare donc à des moments difficiles
mais brigitte bourguignon la présidente
de la commission denquête affiche son
ouverture les propositions d'audition
c'est l'opposition surtout qui va les
proposer
et puis ensuite nous aussi on pourra en
proposer bien sûr et moi par principe je
m'opposerai à aucune des auditions parce
que personne n'a intérêt à s'opposer des
auditions
quelle qu'elle soit les auditions
devraient commencer à mi juin ministres
hauts fonctionnaires médecins la liste
promet d'être longue
edouard philippe et agnès buzyn tous
deux candidats aux municipales ne seront
entendus qu'après le second tour j'ai le
gens nous avaient entendu damien abad le
président des républicains qui sera vice
président de cette commission denquête
je suis aussi nous sommes tous les deux
voilà il ya quatre vice présidents dont
damien abad et votre serviteur et votre
serviteur vous vous dites et on l'entend
lui dire il n'y aura pas tribunal
populaire est ce que vous craignez quand
même une affaire banale abyss pas du
tout pas du tout nous ne sommes pas du
tout dans le même schéma
nous sommes sur une analyse qui complexe
et qui justifie parfaitement cette
commission denquête nous ne nous sommes
pas fait imposer cette commission
denquête nous la souhaitons avec la même
intensité avec la même énergie que les
groupes d'opposition
elle est indispensable mais eric ciotti
qu'est nommé rapporteur général de la
commission denquête n'a vraiment pas été
le plus tendre avec vous justin on
attendait mais mais mais il n'y a pas
une question de tendresse ou pas de
tendresse
eric ce type dit quoi dans votre
reportage il dit nous voulons connaître
la vérité eh bien oui nous voulons nous
aussi connaît ça veut dire qu'une
mission d'information qui existait avant
puisque en fait cette commission enquête
est issu de la mission d'information n'a
pas permis c'est de faire tout dans leur
objet non brigitte boucher leurs objets
radicalement différent la mission
d'information était là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement pendant la
gestion de la crise sanitaire sous tous
les aspects d'ailleurs pas que sanitaire
économique social et comprendre les
mesures du gouvernement
le confinement le de confinement le
rythme les mesures de protection les
mesures de prévention c'était ça son
objet est ce qu eric ciotti là le temps
la vérité commence on n'est plus dans le
temps la communication locale à dire ça
c'est de la communication et ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup non
la commission denquête elle doit
comprendre pourquoi et comment nous
avons géré cette crise la guerre est un
état d c'est important et pas simplement
sur ce qui a commencé au mois de mars
tout ce qui a précédé et qui fait que le
système sanitaire a bien répondu sur
certains aspects
à moins à moins bien répondu sur
d'autres comprendre et surtout
l'objectif de tout ça c'est que nous en
tirions des enseignements utiles pour la
suite
vous savez moi je vais vous dire très
clairement nous sommes extrêmement
serein sur la manière dont les choses
ont été menées nous avions un objectif
très clair qui a été partagé avec les
français dès le début éviter la
saturation dans les hôpitaux
évitez souvenez-vous nous avions sous sa
en esprit que nous soyons obligés de
faire des tris entre les malades ça n'a
jamais eu lieu et si c'était ça et c'est
parce que ça a été bien gérée maintenant
est-ce que sur certains points président
de la république l'avait dit le 13 avril
ya pu y avoir des défaillances ya pu
avoir des insuffisances dans la gestion
quand nous le découvrons qu'à faire
cette journée masque oui et aussi des
produits actifs quand nous avons
découvert que l'essentiel des produits
actifs des produits de raimu de
réanimation étaient produits par des
pays étrangers
ça c'est des choses qui sont
inacceptables mais c'est pas la
responsabilité de notre gouvernement
geste chaîne toute une histoire
oui sur la gestion des masques
n'auriez-vous pas mieux fait d'admettre
dès le début de la crise qu'il y avait
une pénurie de masques
incité par exemple les français à
fabriquer les leurres plutôt que de dire
à l'époque on se rappelle tout de même
ses membres de dire que les masques ne
servait à rien que les français ne
seraient pas les mettre est ce que vous
voulez mais tu es aujourd'hui que c'est
vraiment je pense que c'était une erreur
de dire ça mais c'était pas une erreur
qui a été fait au hasard
au même moment l'organisation mondiale
de la santé disait la même chose vous
savez ce qui caractérise et ça c'est un
des résultats de la mission
d'information c'était pas pour cacher la
biométrie non non non non non une erreur
vous leur comité
c'est une erreur defacto puisque c'était
un point d'accès un point de fixation
qui a été un élément perturbateur de
tout ce qu'on pouvait faire de très bien
par ailleurs
mais vous savez c'est une des choses qui
est apparu de façon très claire pendant
la mission d'information lors qu'on a eu
17 audition donc on a fait du travail
sérieux c'est de voir comment sur cette
crise
les vérités se sont apparus de manière
successive parfois contradictoires dans
le temps et parfois contradictoires à un
même moment entre différentes sources
les autorités scientifiques n'étaient
pas d'accord sur tout à tout moment et
ce aujourd'hui ça reconnaissait qu on
veut que les stocks de masques étaient 1
suffisant mais il l'était à l'évidence
mais il était à l'évidence pour des
situations sanitaires que toute façon il
était extrêmement difficile de prévoir
et d'anticiper
je pense que là dessus on ne nous y
reprendra pas mais quand je dis nous
c'est pas le gouvernement
c'est le pays c'est la france c'est son
organisation il ya une responsabilité
des exécutifs antérieures pour vous
justement la gauche les communistes 10
la raison pour laquelle vous avez
accepté cette commission d' enquête de
la part de la droite et pas celle que
voulait les communistes et parce que
vous êtes lié c'est parce que évident
que vous avez tous eu les mêmes
responsabilités vous avez tous été faits
exacts c'est trop facile
la proposition de la commission du
groupe gdr a été refusée tout simplement
parce qu'elle est apparue av
après que nous avions décidé de
transformer la mission d'information en
commission denquête nous l'avions dit
dès le début c'est pas une mesure
opportuniste la commission denquête dès
le début le président richard ferrand
avait dit première phase mission
d'information pour exercer la pression
des républicains ont exercé non nous
étions très déterminé nous l'avions même
mis dans la loi pour que les douches et
nous avions même dit que il y avait dans
la loi d'urgence la première celle du 23
mars
l'obligation que le gouvernement
viennent périodiquement rendre des
comptes à la représentation nationale
sur la manière dont était géré la crise
c'était le rôle de cette mission
organise butin qui a parlé hors
commission denquête puisqu'elle n'était
pas constituée elle a parlé dans le
monde elle a parlé de mascarade à propos
des municipales elle a dit qu'elle avait
alerté très tôt le couple exécutif est
ce que vous craignez qu'à l'issue de
cette commission denquête il ya des
têtes qui doivent tomber mais non ce
n'est pas un tribunal une commission
denquête une commission dans quel
parlement comptabilité communiquent par
le moteur a des pouvoirs très puissant
et c'est d'ailleurs très utile var
judiciaire non non non non non non nous
voir il y avoir de poursuites
judiciaires ou initier la commission et
le parlement n'a pas pourquoi je dis ça
mais en revanche il a des pouvoirs de
contrainte de ce2 de convoquer on ne
peut pas s'y soustraire
honte honte on témoigne sous serment
donc c'est très solennelle est relevé et
c'est très bien comme ça moi je défends
cette initiative de la défense sans
réserve mais je n'ai aucune crainte sur
le fait que la vérité qui apparaîtra
sera une vérité utile et pas une vérité
polémique alléger les gens dans poursuit
cette émission avec
a sion d'un dixième groupe à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
deux groupes parlementaires ont vu le
jour en deux semaines à l'assemblée avec
des députés issus en partie de la
république en marche avec dix groupes le
record est battu sous la vème république
hégémonique au début du quinquennat le
groupe majoritaire connaît une lente
érosion les explications de stéphane
idées claires sur un pont de paris juste
devant l'assemblée se joue une drôle de
scène
voici 17 députés à peine des confiné ils
viennent d'annoncer la création d'un
nouveau groupe au palais bourbon
tous ou presque étaient des élus en
marche
les voici en dissidence
[Applaudissements]
le groupe s'appelle écologie démocratie
solidarité
c'est le neuvième groupe à l'assemblée
un record sous la vème république
une semaine plus tard quelques mètres
plus loin
l'histoire se répète voici encore 17
députés
mais ce ne sont pas les mêmes on prend
ses distances et on pose pour la photo
voici le dixième groupe qui vient de
naître
il s'appelle agir ensemble deux nouveaux
groupes en une semaine
le premier se veut une alternative plus
à gauche plus écologiste que la
république en marche
on est vraiment à un tournant après
cette crise sanitaire où il ya des
décisions qui vont être prises qui vont
être structurantes pour l'avenir de la
france pour l'avenir de la planète
donc nous on veut peser sur ses
décisions pour que la sortie de crise
soient marquées par une justice sociale
et par une justice environnementale
l'autre groupe agir ensemble est au
centre droit proches d'edouard philippe
il comprend aussi sept députés de la
république en marche
nous pensons que face à la vague qui est
en train de déferler qui dit il faut
démondialiser déconstruire l'europe
revenir à l'état providence des années
80 nous pensons que c'est tout le
contraire
il faut revoir la mondialisation la
rendre plus humaine plus juste mais nous
avons besoin de la mondialisation
ce dixième groupe s'inscrit clairement
dans la majorité pour le 9e c'est ni
majorité ni opposition mais à eux deux
ces nouveaux groupes ont débauché 14
députés marcheurs ils font donc perdre
la majorité absolue ou groupe la
république en marche pas vraiment une
surprise plutôt le résultat d'une lente
érosion en 2017 il y avait 300 14
marcheurs à l'assemblée aujourd'hui ils
ne sont plus que 280 j le genre de
groupe ont vu le jour en moins de deux
semaines ici à l'assemblée nationale il
ya désormais dix groupes
à quand le 11e à écouter ça n'est pas
moi qu'il créerait c'est ça la question
je la porte est ouverte il y en avoir
d'autres écoutez par définition on vient
d'en avoir l'exemple la création des
groupes est libre ça n'est pas
souhaitable
ça n'est pas souhaitable c'est un
facteur de confusion dix groupes à
l'assemblée nationale ça ne s'est jamais
vu et c'est probablement quelque chose
qui va compliquer le fonctionnement
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale est capable d'accueillir et
d'absorber mais ça ne va pas faciliter
ni clarifier le travail parlementaire
après vous va faire avec président du
groupe de la république en marche c'est
un échec personnel que ses divisions
dans c'est une déception c'est un regret
mais ça n'est pas un échec personnel ou
jeunes est fragilisé pas du tout je ne
porte en rien seule la responsabilité de
tout le fonctionnement d'une majorité
d'une relation entre un cliquetis
quelque chose à un moment ce groupe mais
je me le dis tous les jours brigitte
boucher tous les jours je me dis que
nous pourrions faire mieux
nous pourrions faire mieux et je
pourrais faire mieux
écoutez on ne retient pas les gens
contre leur gré il n'y a pas d' acte
d'autorité dans un groupe parlementaire
tout ça est le résultat d'un moment très
évident qu est cette crise si
particulière dont nous disions un mot au
tout début qui évidemment
probablement agite un certain nombre
d'esprits créer un certain nombre d'
aspiration ou libère un certain nombre
de d'énergie qui était déjà en jeu et
qui se sont exprimés dans la création
remonte quand même bien plus loin en
tout cas une aile du groupe notamment
qui s'est sentie inaudible qui est parti
du 1er mai moi d'abord je n'ai jamais
raisonné en termes d le gaucher del
droite au sein du groupe est ce que je
constate c'est que plusieurs choses
premièrement tout ça ne déstabilise en
rien la majorité nous avons 344 députés
de la majorité dont 281 en marche
sur 577 députés donc non seulement la
majorité est solide dans je vous signale
à l'une et à l'autre que jamais jamais
une voix n'a manqué au gouvernement
depuis trois ans sur quelques textes que
ce soit et c'est ça ma mission je
regrettais plein de choses je peux dire
qu'on aurait fait plein de choses
formidables
mais le boulot il a été fait là dessus
par ailleurs nous restons le groupe en
marche
l'épiné dorsale de cette majorité et
faire 2 181 sur 340 coutances davantage
avec l'origine en avant mais je puisse
jouer depuis le premier jour maintenant
tu puisses mais non mais ni plus ni
moins depuis le premier jour je ne sais
pas que je compose
mais je travaille avec le modem nous
nous voyons toutes les semaines avec
patrick mignola et avec nos équipes
respectives et nous voyons sur quel vote
sur quel sujet comment nous allons voter
comme on s'y retrouve pas aurélien tâche
et a dit si je veux rester de gauche
doit quitter le large et long car ce
sont des démarches personnelles vous
oblige à tenir les promesses de 2017 je
pense à la bioéthique je pense à la
réforme des retraites
à toutes ces réformes les leçons de la
roja réforme bioéthique nous la voterons
et le plus tôt sera le mieux nous
l'adopterons définitivement avant la fin
du quinquennat mais mais pas seulement
avant la fin des quinas beaucoup plus
vite que la fin du quinquennat
j'ai dit à l'hôtel projeter vos
confrères d'une autre chaîne de
télévision que ça serait très difficile
avant l'été si c'est possible pourquoi
pas mais j'ai du mal à l'imaginer mais
très vite après l'été il faut que cette
loi soit adoptée les retraites c'est
différent les circonstances
ont changé et notamment la question du
financement des retraites la question du
travail prendre évidemment une autre
couleur à l'aune de la crise que nous
vivons est donc il faudra probablement
l'adapter nous avons la semaine
prochaine et la semaine suivante à
discuter d'une proposition de loi sur
les retraites agricoles
c'est à dire une manière de rentrer dans
le sujet nous allons voir de quelle
manière nous le ferons donc là il faudra
probablement adapter les choses
mais vous savez d'abord ces deux groupes
n'ont rien à voir il ya un groupe qui
est sorti de la majorité est un groupe
qui vient d'y rentrer de façon très
claire c'est le groupe je vous l'avais
dit sacrée graine de la confusion
abel la multiplicité des groupes dans le
dans le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
nationale puisque vous en êtes l'une et
l'autre familière c'est incontestable
mais ensuite on vivra avec et sur la
majorité maintenant elle a trois par
trois mouvements trois groupes
d'importance très différente 17 membres
pour agir ensemble 46 membres pour le
modem 2 181 membres pour la république
en marche
allez on avance et on va parler d'une
proposition de loi de la droite
sénatoriale pour faciliter le vote lors
du second tour des élections municipales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat a adopté un texte pour
favoriser procuration et vote par
correspondance
mardi la chambre haute a débattu ce
texte issu des républicains objectif
améliorer la participation lors du
second tour des municipales fixées le 28
juin le gouvernement est contre fayard
et caire sur le déroulement du second
tour des municipales sénat et
gouvernement ne sont que partiellement
d'accord
objectif de la proposition de loi de la
droite et du centre contré l'abstention
record du premier tour notamment en
facilitant le vote par procuration il
nous paraît tout à fait essentiel que
des mesures soient prises pour rassurer
et nous comptions le faire en parfaite
harmonie avec le gouvernement et la
majorité parlementaire
car il s'agit d'un impératif d'intérêt
supérieur pour le bon fonctionnement de
la démocratie
le sénat a donc adopté le texte mais
contre l'avis du gouvernement qui entend
portant reprendre à son compte certaines
propositions des sénateurs votre
proposition de loi comprend des mesures
utiles et le gouvernement les partage
mais encore une fois pardon d'insister
de souligner le fait qu'elle ne relève
pas du domaine de la loi
aussi sont elles susceptibles d'être
mises en oeuvre et je le redis comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure par décret voire
même par simple circulaire le texte des
sénateurs proposent de porter d'une à
deux le nombre de procurations pour un
mandataire et veut assouplir les règles
de la procuration à domicile en
direction des personnes fragiles le
sénat veut aussi permettre à une
personne de donner procuration un
mandataire même s'il n'est pas inscrit
sur la même liste électorale
à condition qu'il s'agisse d'un proche
le gouvernement est contre contre aussi
le rétablissement du vote par
correspondance
un des points majeurs de cette
proposition de loi qui la sortie de
garanties pour prévenir la fraude
il nous semble que la faisabilité
juridique et technique de la mise en
place du vote par correspondance à ce
stade paraît très délicate à mettre en
oeuvre ou nous proposer le vote par
correspondance aux calendes grecques
c'est à dire c'est qu'à landes qui
n'existe pas le gouvernement qui
présente son propre projet de loi au
parlement
débattue le 5 juin l'assemblée nationale
le texte prévoit la possibilité
d'annuler le second tour en cas de
reprise de l'épidémie
j'ai de loi qui devrait également abrité
plusieurs dispositions relatives au
déroulement de ce second tour
gilles l'agente sur le fond ne faut-il
pas faciliter le vote par procuration le
vote par correspondance dès le prochain
scrutin de façon urgente pour avoir un
minimum de participation mais ça n'est
pas raisonnable ça n'est pas résolu ça
n'est techniquement pas réaliste même
réglementaires rappelle que le vote par
correspondance a été supprimée en 1975
parce que il fonctionnait fort mal et
qui ne garantissait pas une sincérité en
un soc 15 ans oui ça veut dire que le
vote par correspondance n'est pas la
panacée et que ça se travaille et que
les élections municipales du second tour
étant dans trois semaines
il n'est pas raisonnable de vouloir le
faire dès maintenant est-ce qu'il va pas
y avoir un problème de sincérité du
scrutin le 28 juin c'est ce que
plusieurs élans neurologue et senna et
romain trilles en or et 1 il y en aurait
tu as s'ils nous battent lions le vote
par correspondance et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement et
partisans d'être prudent mais vous savez
il en sera de ce domaine comme dans
beaucoup d'autres nous aurons des leçons
à tirer de cette crise et notamment
probablement faire évoluer les pratiques
électorales mais le faire à froid
sérieusement en série ayant tous les
aspects de la question il ya quelque
chose qu'on peut faire rapidement
c'est en rock l'autorisation de deux
procurations par personne aujourd'hui
sera déroulé le 28 juin je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
envisageable est souhaitable on va
réglementer mais mais mais était
d'ailleurs dans le dans la même ville
dans la même commune ne faisons pas
sauter parce que là pour le coup il ya
des problèmes de vérification qui dans
l'urgence risquerait d'être mal
organisés et malgré un mode et
municipales des accords ont été conclus
entre les républicains et la république
en marche avec des mouvements politiques
à clermont c'est notre politique pour
effet de bouche et beaucoup entre les
matches est ce que ça veut dire que la
république en marche pour chats droite
certainement pas certainement pas et je
le dis et c'est d'ailleurs non sans
rapport avec ce que nous nous sommes dit
sur les aigles et les groupes et la
création des nouveaux groupes
le mouvement la république en marche
sous l'impulsion de stanislas guérini
sous l'impulsion forte courageuse et
utile de stanislas
eni et le groupe reste les lieux du
dépassement politique du dépassement du
clivage droite gauche
non pas pour nier l'existence des
sensibilités les uns et les autres nous
sommes le fruit d'une histoire politique
de convictions politiques que nous
n'avons jamais abdiqué mais nous
reconnaissons depuis 2010 est que ce
clivage a plutôt était a plutôt été un
facteur de conservatisme de frein dans
l'évolution dans les progrès du pays
qu'il importe de dépasser et ce qui
était vrai en 2017
elle est encore plus aujourd'hui ou pour
trouver les bonnes réponses à la crise
économique à la crise sociale
nous devons être très imaginatif et nous
débarrasser des oripeaux des vieilles
solutions des vieilles des vieilles
méthodes des solutions toutes faites
comme je les voit réapparaître et sur le
flanc droit et sur le flanc gauche donc
plus que jamais nous devons nous départ
il ne reste une minute on va terminer
avec le rapport sévère rendu par la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur la
gestion de l'incendié de lubrizol les
sénateurs dénoncent des angles morts
inacceptables dans la prévention des
risques industriels en france
il pointe la responsabilité de l'état il
critique la communication de l'exécutif
et critique notamment agnès buzyn est ce
que ça ne fait pas un nouveau caillou
dans la chaussure dans cette campagne
agnès buzyn à les critiquer avec eux
tout ce qu'elle a pu dire pendant la
campagne de paris et puis maintenant
encore ça ne m'attendais quel est
l'élément central de ce rapport et que
je trouve fondé sait les difficultés de
communication qui ont eu lieu mais
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
important dans une crise comme ça c'est
la gestion réelle de la crise sur lequel
porte aucun reproche
c'est à dire notamment en termes de
réactivité de rapidité des réponses à
apporter
ou est ce que c'est la communication
vous savez quand une crise surgit comme
ça vous n'avez pas immédiatement le bon
ton le bon discours cela aussi ce qui
est important c'est les leçons qu'on en
tire et le ministre elisabeth baume la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire a déjà lancé la concertation
qui va permettre de tirer les leçons
elle a déjà décidé d'augmenter de 50%
les contrôles des sites classés donc de
tous ces événements
sont souvent une ou deux missions de la
fin merci gilles legendre le vouloir
plus merci tu as mais aussi bien
évidemment la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro hebdo
[Musique]